[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
June 9th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
the rising cost of airfares and hotel
rooms has made it a lot more expensive
to travel this summer compared to last
year and then there are the fees travel
columnist Don Gilbertson joins us so
Dawn we saw Airlines and other travel
companies eliminate some fees during the
pandemic is the return of so many fees
the clearest sign to date that you know
we've returned to normal I mean it is
definitely one sign I mean some fees
didn't go away the most notable fee that
did go away during the pandemic in fact
permanently in many cases are those
airline ticket change fees they used to
be as much as 200 or 250 a ticket so
those are gone for good but people need
to know that doesn't apply to all
airline tickets you've been with us
before talking about fees on basic
economy tickets are those on the rise
they're not necessarily On The Rise just
a lot of people don't realize that
they're back you know because Airlines
permanently eliminated change fees on
regular tickets you know during the
pandemic they're back on basic economy
tickets so in some cases you know on
those No Frill tickets you can't change
at all and others you'll still pay a fee
of you know 100 to 200 if you can change
them so it's just really something
Travelers have to keep in mind you know
when they click Buy on the cheapest
ticket you know when President Biden
talked about going to war against junk
fees a few months ago he mentioned fees
on on airline tickets
has anything come about from that
nothing yet obviously all these fees and
this industry is under a microscope by
President Biden and the U.S Department
of Transportation but those proposals
tend to take quite a long time to Wind
Through the government so we haven't
seen anything solid on that front yet
now Airline fees are often Public Enemy
Number One but as you wrote in your
reporting hotels have gotten in on the
ACT also what should people reserving
hotel rooms watch out for obviously
Resort fees are you know Enemy Number
One when it comes to hotels I was in Las
Vegas the resort fee at the hotels I
stayed in was you know between forty and
fifty dollars a night mandatory but you
know we all know about those fees
generally but then there's some smaller
fees that people need to be aware of you
know a lot of people today maybe want to
have say Amazon groceries delivered to
the hotel or something they forgot a lot
of hotels charge a package handling fee
Marriott charges uh ten dollars just to
have a package delivered to the room
yeah to the front desk yep now you spoke
to a California resident who found a
long list list of fees on his hotel bill
what were they charging him for well
yeah he didn't realize it till he got
home you know so many of us don't this
is one thing that you know Travelers
really need to pay attention to so many
people don't look at their receipt you
know until they get home and it's too
late to you know go to the front desk
and say whoa what is this and this man
he was at a conference in Scottsdale
Arizona and he found a 10 Bellman
gratuity he didn't use the Bellman he
found a three dollar daily housekeeping
fee and he had already left cash for the
housekeeper and then he found a credit
card processing fee which I have not
come across very frequently so he wasn't
very happy yeah I can imagine now if
somebody does leave money for the
housekeeping staff is there a way to get
out of that fee that might be applied by
the hotel later on I mean you can
certainly try you know I mean my Mo with
all these types of fees is to talk to
the front desk I mean say the resort fee
say you know it covers the pool and it
covers all this different stuff and you
didn't use that or it was closed during
your stay I believe you have a
legitimate case for saying can you
please remove this from my room and I
did that as recently as this weekend oh
what happened to you I had a flight
cancellation on an airline that shall be
unnamed at the moment and I was stranded
in Las Vegas so I checked into this
hotel at 1am at my own expense and the
resort fee was going to be 40 and I was
leaving the next day and I'm like you
know what I'm not going to use any of
your amenities would you kindly take it
off and she did you can also get kind of
expensive to rent a car so what kind of
fees are creeping into people's bills
there another area to really pay close
attention to I've heard from some
readers who looked at their bill and saw
like a 15 or 16 dollar fuel service
charge when they had filled up the tank
so really be careful and get a receipt
and don't leave that lot until they
acknowledge the receipt that the gas
tank is indeed full so you can avoid
that fee another one that I came across
pretty much by accident I was on the
phone with a airline CEO on an interview
and he was returning a Tesla to the
Hartford airport and he hadn't charged
it fully and they dinged him 35 dollars
oh wow so this is a case where people
need to really read the fine print on
their contracts really well oh for sure
just pay attention you know or ask they
upgraded him to a Tesla at no charge he
thought he'd try one he was in a rush
you know and just didn't charge it and I
never heard of that fee I mean it makes
perfect sense but I had never heard of
it by the way I read in your column
about restaurants charging people for
ice in their drink how is that going
over well you know this whole craft
cocktail boom right and so there was a
case in Las Vegas at the luxury Wind
Resort where somebody posted a receipt
that showed a 3.50 craft ice fee and I
reached out to the hotel and it turns
out they are changing suppliers and that
fee will no longer be charged can't make
this up
what power do Travelers have here you
mentioned that you can go to the front
desk but other ways to avoid paying some
of these fees by the way that you make
the reservation yes for sure I mean
there's certain places Las Vegas for one
of them it's very very very hard to
avoid Resort fees in Las Vegas but in
other cities you know say in New York or
Chicago they may be known as a different
thing like destination fees or amenity
fees but there are some that don't
charge them so in your shopping click on
those taxes and fee details and if
there's something there that rubs you
the wrong way don't stay there book
somewhere else I talked to a traveler
last week who a super frequent flyer
stays in Marriott all the time and it's
not a resort it's a City Hotel in Boston
and he decided he's not staying there
anymore because they were charging this
fee and he got no use out of it that's
Wall Street Journal travel columnist Don
Gilbertson and that's it for your money
briefing this week our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris sinsley I'm
your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
thank you